today is a day for truth the world needs  to know what happened and to know what  he stands for that kind of power is very  dangerous let the record show that this  committee holds him responsible that's  how it starts the fever the rage of  turns good men cruel  this bat vigilantes like a one-man reign  of terror you don't get to decide what  the right thing is nobody cares about  Clark Kent taking on the Batman  being something all some people have  it's all that gives them hope people  hate what they don't understand be their  hero Clark  anything they need you to be or be none  of it you don't know this world a thing  you never did  twenty years in Gotham I mean good guys  are left I'm gonna stay that way  Devil's don't come from Hell beneath us  they come from the sky  [Music]  he has the power to wipe out the entire  human race  nobody has to destroy him  black and blue  God versus man  day versus night  the red capes are coming through red  capes are coming  you